yeah i think we're here i hear them i
hear somebody there we go the technology
has been fixed
robert woods joining us now rams
receiver robert got to ask you we played
the highlight of the touchdown you
scored in the playoffs against the
seahawks and you threw the ball into the
stands
surely you don't get fined for throwing
the ball into stands when no one's there
no definitely not and i was actually
reaching for uh
seattle's family section i was aiming
for them
sending them home with a souvenir gift
did you get it there like just you know
how how close did you get it
i'm not not close enough chris i neither
needed your arm
okay go ahead mike speaking of arms
big news this offseason obviously the
trade that brings matthew stafford
to the rams where were you when you
found out and what was your reaction
yeah i was at home i saw the news
uh shocked um
shocked and excited and at the same time
um
shocked because you know what we built
with jared goff um just our history
getting to the super bowl
being able to uh join la and and
really expand my receiver career with
him in this offense
and then um just just how kind of just
i felt sudden you know sudden how quick
he left us
but then um being excited right away to
uh add a guy like matthew stafford
seeing what he's um done in detroit um
spreading the ball all around um high
caliber guy
finds ways to throw the ball with his
over the top side arm
and really just a green and grind kind
of guy i can't wait to see what he
brings for our offense
yeah i mean none of us can i you know
one more thing just about like the jared
goff thing robert like that
did you get a sense or have any feel you
know as
a part of the team that the relationship
might be going in the wrong way i mean i
know us in the media with john wolford
and some of that stuff at the end of the
the regular season in playoffs we
thought maybe they were falling out of
love as far as mcveigh and goff but did
you have any sense of that at all
now i'll say it's always is is tough
love and his offensiveness
um you want to compete you want to win
um
you're obviously going to have some
confrontation with guys
uh so it's all a competitive nature so
no not really everything that we saw was
um got two guys competing when to win
right um
always at all times
so the page turns to a new quarterback
in matthew stafford when did you first
make contact with him
and has there been any effort to get
together and catch some passes from
matthew stafford
yeah literally i want to say later that
night or the next night
i was i was on the phone with stafford
uh you gotta get in good
uh especially as receivers in our
offense you gotta get to work and get
your quarterback quick
um just just bring them aboard let them
know how we're excited we're to have
them
um in our offense uh
gonna get with them soon when i get back
to la and really just
get this ball rolling and want to get
our timing down um first year with them
and want to look good and
get these numbers right back well like
now i want you to speak i mean we know
stafford's got talent you got talent
like what's your head coach going to be
like with a guy like that
like explain explain some mcvay
wednesday morning energy to us anyways
like what can he what's he like and now
what do you think he's gonna be like
with a guy like stafford
yeah just coming in i would say
wednesday morning uh
been away from the team monday tuesday
he's probably not sleeping drawing up
plays
and really i would say wednesday morning
whenever we see him he's fired up super
excited
really just installing all day uh many
many plays exciting plays
trick plays um just finding different
ways to get guys to ball and i think
with a guy like stafford
um being able to move in the pocket and
make all types of throws
i think he'll be very excited for uh all
of our receivers our tight ends
um even the cam makers coming out the
back field
you mentioned cam akers and sean mcvay
has been very complementary of him he
believes he can become the every down
guy what have you seen from acres
based on his rookie season that would
cause you to possibly believe the
running game and that presence from the
running back is going to be a big part
of the offense moving forward yeah i
think last year it was just a credit to
our coaches and guys around them malcolm
brown daryl henderson
really kind of easing them into it
coaching them up
um and i think by time the end of the
season it was it was
can't make her show really um and really
at the beginning stages really
talking to cam and noah cam he has a
competitive guy who wants to
be out there on the field he's one more
one that carries he's like you know let
me get more
um and then what you what you see it
coming to play later in the season him
getting his touches getting his carries
you see he's a guy who's ready to carry
this team in the backfield
uh in our ground game and uh making guys
miss for sure super exciting back
um year two we'll see what he has
i gotta ask about another you know freak
the freak of nature in the nfl
like aaron donald all right i mean just
to like
speak to speak about him the athletic
specimen
like can can he take the wide receivers
and some bag drills and cone drills with
as quick as his feet are
yeah i would say so you see him in the
off-season that's all he
does really is running back drills and
receiver drills and i think that really
gives him the edge because he's so much
quicker than the guys he go against his
hands his feet
um he's able to do some of these moves
that skill positions do on these linemen
and it really makes his match-up unfair
um
even when you do have two guys match up
against him he has the strength
to go with it so it's really a
combination of speed and power
that he brings to that position really
rare robert
uh matthew stafford not the only new
addition on offense receiver desean
jackson joins the team
how does that in your mind change what
you guys were doing last year as a
passing attack
i think just uh his speed um the threat
of him
um going past this i want to say he
leads all receivers all time
with uh was it 60 plus
sketches 60 yard catches or 50 yard
catches um so he's definitely the
one of the best deep directs the nfl in
the game has seen
so to bring them to our offense um
is super exciting super dangerous for us
allows things to open up all around the
field
uh underneath down down deep uh
and then with our screen game that mcvay
brings um
just ball carriers put it in his hands
quick put in our hands quick
um good guys out in front and let us run
use our speed
like i robert i know you're a
professional
you love football you love working on
your craft
you know we had a conversation like
there's this you know this new talk with
the nfl pa
and the off-season workout conversation
you know
mike just brought up yeah you got a new
stafford you know got a new desean
jackson i know you like practicing
football and doing that stuff
like are you one that's in favor of the
no off season workouts or do you want to
be in the facility getting after it a
little bit
yeah i'm in favor of uh of guys coming
back
ready i think last year you saw you saw
the maturity of guys to being able to
come back ready uh prepared know the
offense
um come back physically ready as well
and i think
uh and year right in year nine right now
um
experiencing many different off-seasons
knowing what it takes to come back ready
knowing how to prepare i think um
i think this is kind of like where is
going right now and even
bringing the young guys along last year
we were able to bring
our rookies out to california get some
throwing sessions with them
teach them uh different techniques that
the coaches may not know
um just by experience in different ways
um so last year i think it was just a
little
teaser and a taste of what uh guys can
do and get done in the off season you
saw a lot of guys
branch off as well um and handle some
social justice issues
um this offseason i partnered with
castrol to clean up our communities
um there's many different things and
take the guys are taking advantage of
this time to come back ready and still
have an impact in their
in their local areas i tell you robert
that was a seamless transition
professional to the fact that
castrol has made you available to us
today so go ahead and continue to tell
us more about what you're currently
doing with castrol
yeah recently just partnered up with
castrol uh we just did a cleanup in los
angeles
uh right there in los angeles invited
many volunteers to come out
and partner with us clean the streets
really just trying to cut back and
keep our environment sustainable reduce
our impact any ways we can electricity
um cleaning up after ourselves using
public transportation
really finding any ways possible to help
impact our cities
man i love it you know my nickname is
captain planet man that's
i mean man you just you got a new fan in
me all right i mean i'm on the robert
woods squad now for sure
like really like that's awesome thing to
be a part of like seriously
congratulations on that
um i gotta i gotta ask you this cause
you know the single digits conversation
that's coming up right
you know i correct me if i'm wrong you
were a number you were number two in
college right yeah the deuce like me
i love it no i know so so are you gonna
make like is that like if that happens
are you asking for that number right
away you're gonna try to make that
change
yeah right away definitely just being um
number two my whole life
um always was the deuce the deuces loose
um
so just being able to get the two back
playing in la
award at usc and all the local fans
um it's really rare you know gotta jump
on the opportunity to wear the two uh in
the hometown
um it's a must yeah
there are always unintended consequences
though robert when rules
change and if and when the nfl does
open up single digits to running backs
receivers tight ends linebackers and
defensive backs
you're gonna i don't know how you're
gonna resolve it jaylen ramsey already
wants number two
is this a seniority thing you've been
there longer how does this is it tug of
war
is it is it arm wrestling what do you do
to figure out who gets number two
oh just a little sit down and talk with
him we already had a little
words as you can see on social media
discussing it too i know he's
jalen 2.0 but we might just have to
you know we're number zero you know
bringing that into place
um but yeah that would be a conversation
we got to have but
he knows who who's who's in it and who's
been rocking it
he he didn't even wear number two in
college you did
like that's what you should be able to
say like you can't jump on it now it's
too late
he was too late he never wore it he
doesn't know how to wear it right
he was number eight in college there's
no doubt about
so all right here what here's one thing
i'm just like for fun
fascinated by is just your offense
the speed sweeps the fake speed sweeps
all that stuff oh you're doing all this
running before the snap sometimes
do you have to tell mcveigh every now
and then like hey i need a break stop
sending me in motion or does he keep
track of that how does that work
a little bit of everything um really
just you know
off seasons you gotta know get prepared
you know you're working out condition
for these
these fly sweeps and he's fake um and
then that practice you you know you're
doing them you run
them and uh you know he's professional
he wants to have these plays repeated at
times
and it's really really cool having a
young coach because he'll take some of
these reps
he'll take these fly sweeps for you um
so that's pretty cool to see him run out
there and uh
really be me youthful and really be a
player sometimes with the guys yeah
robert last one from me you look at the
nfc west the division the rams are in
top to bottom the best division in the
nfl
do you like that or do you at times say
man it'd be great to be in the nfc east
no no we love it we want to go against
the best guys want to go
in there and compete obviously you want
to make it to the playoffs but you don't
want the easy route you want to be able
to
have some competition play the guys to
where once you get to that caliber
a high caliber play in the playoffs you
experience it you know how to handle it
and uh you don't shy for shy away from
it
and um really in the nfl i mean you you
want to go against the best guys you
want to play them twice
so it's really great we get to see
seattle get to see san fran get to see
arizona who's loading up
with players um trying to get there get
their team in the playoffs but
it's really a loaded uh conference um
loaded division
um so we gotta go through the best if we
wanna win it
well hey robert all the best to you we
appreciate some of your time thanks to
castrol as well work on that arm so you
can get the ball to the seattle
family section coming up this year you
may have to throw over some fans this
time around though hopefully the fans
will be
at all stadiums this year thanks again
for your time and and uh
congratulations on your success and best
wishes this year
we appreciate it thank you guys for
having me thanks robert keep up the good
fight man love it man
robert woods number 17 for now soon to
be number two
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports